assalamu alaikum greetings and peace how
you guys doing
someone sent me this video and i want to
respond to it i thought it's very
important
and i promise you we can pick up some
really good points on here some really
good advice
that can benefit everybody christian
muslim
you name it we're going to watch this
together and again this is not to
make fun of anybody because there are a
lot of people doing
things like you're going to be seeing
this guy doing you know people doing
jumping jacks for jesus
push shelter you know all sorts of
things in the name of god
i love you god boom i love you god
oh many people will benefit inshallah
from this let's watch this
and then we'll go ahead and derive some
benefits uh
please excuse some of the noise in the
background put on salvation as your
helmet
and take the sword
of the spirit which is the word of god
jesus christ
so put on the arm of god
jesus christ we love you god so we do it
for god
jesus christ
of truth jesus christ
okay i think that's enough i mean the
video continues to go on but i think we
get the point now
some people might be laughing when they
see this i mean i really have a
um a sad feeling in myself when i see
things like this
and this is not putting anybody down but
these this is the thing that i
really want to leave you guys with the
three components
that are detrimental that are extremely
important
that are necessary for someone to have
success
in this area of getting nearness of
getting closeness
to the crater that heavens and earth one
thing i want to mention is right off the
bat
we love jesus as muslims we love jesus
you cannot be a muslim muslim meaning
one who has submitted his or her will to
the creator of the heavens and earth
worshiping one and only one god doesn't
make sense
and a lot of times when you see this
kind of stuff you think wow this is what
religion is about you know people
break dancing beat boxing you know doing
these kind of things because they lack
these three components
now pay attention to these three
components so i got that out of the way
we love jesus as a mighty messenger
but you have to know jesus never said
because that's that's the problem here
people
are mixing you know you hear him saying
you have god and then jesus but now
they're mixing the two jesus called
people to worship god
he didn't call people to worship himself
so people many people are misguided in
this area and are confused so we're
doing this to
get people out of the confusion so let
me be quick i don't want to stay too
long
on this but these three points are
important one is the right intention you
got to have the right intention
and then you have to have another
component you have to have the right
knowledge
and then from there you have to take the
right course of action now imagine
somebody sitting on his couch
and let me push these points and home so
you can understand better and the person
wants to get to philadelphia for examine
for example now the person a male or
female he or she's sitting at home and
they have a good intention
they want to get to philadelphia but
they don't have the proper knowledge so
what's going to happen if you don't have
the proper knowledge
and you get a ticket for chicago you
might come see me here at the dean show
but you're not going to get to
philadelphia so the person
didn't do the right homework and the
right research based on knowledge and
evidence
to get the right ticket
to get them to what to philadelphia now
the person might have the right
intention and they might have the right
knowledge
but then that's useless if they don't
take the right
course of action you understand so now
if they're sitting on their couch and
their feet are up and they have a will
to get to god to get to the crater
okay and now they even how many people
you know they know for example that
smoking is bad
but they continue smoking very simple
example
so they didn't take the right action to
get away from cigarettes but now here if
you have the right
knowledge you got to have the right
knowledge you can't just expect to beat
box
uh do push-ups for god uh
do in this case the what's it called the
pop locking and and all this other stuff
you cannot expect to do what you like
because you obviously like doing these
things
so it's kind of like the old example
bringing a
pound of sugar to a diabetic right i
mean
what good is that for the diabetic you
know why don't you find out really what
for instance
you want someone to give you a gift you
like
you don't bring something that you like
a candy bar and then the diabetic can't
eat it and then you eat it because
you bought it because you liked it so
that's not being sincere that's not
being genuine
so we want to now take that to a higher
level you want to go and give
you want to find out what your creator
loves for you to do
what's beneficial for you and that's
what now the beauty of islam
the beauty of islam everything is laid
out what the creator loves
and what the creator hates and all that
is an act of worship
so now we had those three components i
wanted to leave you with the right
intention and that attention is to what
to earn the blessing to favor the mercy
of god out of your deep love
and reverence for god you do you want to
worship him
him and him the creator alone he's not a
male or female
so you now got to get the right
knowledge
and this is where people many people
fail you got to look for the evidence
right you got to look and right now
today we have the living miracle the
quran
and you have it everything tampa free
temperature read the quran
there's a whole chapter in the quran
named after jesus mother
mary and you have in this quran you have
the whole blueprint for life
everything you need to so to be
successful in this life and the
hereafter everything is there
now once you get the right knowledge you
get the right knowledge now you got to
act on that because how many people have
accepted the truth but now they don't
establish the prayer for instance in
islam five times a day
they don't pay the zakat they don't fast
during the month of ramadan these are
all the things that we know hundred
percent
that this is what god almighty
legislated that he is alone to be
worshipped this is the pure monotheism
to to heed
that you don't worship anyone besides
the crate of the heavens and earth and
this is the same
same message that jesus peace be upon
him delivered and moses and abraham all
the messengers of god
they didn't deliver anything different
from each other it was all the same
two philosophers can't agree on one
thing but these messengers did
on the pure monotheism and during jesus
time
you'd have to not worship him nowhere
ever did jesus claim that he was god
the literal son of god but he called
people to only worship the one god
almighty in arabic allah in aramaic
allah
elohim the one god and this is how you
can be successful to start there
but all this pop lock-in break dancing
and all this stuff
this is not going to get you nearness to
your creator you might like doing these
things
and now you're trying to go ahead and
throw this in the mix and
right so we have to distinguish who
jesus was and this is clear in islam
remember islam just means to
to submit your will to the creator of
the heavens and earth thy will be done
so right here this answer your question
it's not your will because you might
want to do these things
you think it's fancy acute feels good
you're
going to the what the next man now going
to the night club for god
the next man or woman they're just
making up things as they go and it
becomes
their way it's not god's way it's your
will not god's will so this is
very important so those three points
very important that you have the right
intention
that you have the right knowledge
that you know for sure based on evidence
that this is indeed what the creator
wants me to do
and we have that in the quran verbatim
word of god and the authentic sayings
the
tradition the prophetic statements of
the last final message of sentiment
kind prophet muhammad peace and blessed
be upon him and then you got to take the
action
you got to work god almighty tells you
what to do you got to do it
he don't need it we need it so i just
wanted to quickly share that with you
and and this is something that is
tremendously important three
these three points and we do this out of
the love that god almighty guides him
you know we pray for people like this
for their guidance and
hopefully god will and inshaallah this
can reach him and
and hopefully people can really take the
matter serious
and help us to really do what god wants
us to do
on his terms and not our desires thank
you very much subscribe if you haven't
already
and hit the notification bell share this
fart and why support us on our patreon
page
and we'll see you next time here on the
dean show peace be with you assalamu
alaikum